hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast 100th
live stream number 100
the q a segment
indeed
while we were off air we were trying to
soar sea lions but we failed uh we
picked up this lovely black cat in the
background tesla and until just a moment
ago there was an epic tabby sitting next
to him but he decided to go be epic
elsewhere
tesla is also going to be elsewhere and
we are losing all of our animal friends
well
i would like to write a
novel the premise of which is a world in
which everything is very much like this
one except that we call sea lions lions
and we call
lions land lions
that's the only difference that's the
only difference except that there will
be a lot of commercials for telephone
service wired to your house that would
play on the idea of landlines i think
all right i have driven conversation to
a halt
and i apologize
i don't know what to say man yeah i
don't really either i did not know where
that was going but then i just heard
myself say landlines and i thought you
know we can use a landing i i got the
marketing uh the marketing plug right
here yep yeah
all right we're gonna start with the
question from the discord this week
apparently i forgot this last week since
it's no longer integrated so we have uh
doesn't matter here we go we got it the
discordant question i don't think so
this is from
for those of you who don't know um
people on our patreon also have access
to the discord and people on discord
every week um
decide vote i guess on which of the
questions that have been posed they most
want to see answered so they wrestled
for it is that wrong virtual wrestling
wrestling
i don't know how these things are done
now you're not the logistics guy
nor have i ever been no even back when
you were the
beer hefe
right
nobody knows what that means but yeah
we'll just leave it there he was the
beer heife
on an island in the middle of the panama
canal
if shaming so the discard question
without leading
if shaming and reputational harm are one
form of establishing dominance and
social media has magnified the scale of
such forces
it seems that we need ways for
institutions to prevent people from
rising to the top who are most willing
to wield such tools of force
what processes inside institutions might
ensure that those using shame and
reputational harm don't have the
greatest advantage in climbing the
institutional hierarchy
um this is a good question
i thought
it's kind of a stumper but i think the
answer looks like
like this now
the key to making many organizations
function
is to have the
ground rules
and
the
rationale for them
at the door
so that by signing up for the
organization you are also signing up for
its
um
it's ethos and its obligations to itself
such that if somebody violates the ethos
that it is costly to them because
everybody else has signed up for the
idea that these are good things and
you and i learned when we taught at
evergreen there's a thing called a
covenant
that one sets out at the beginning of
every
class and it is an agreement basically
between the professor the students and
the students and each other
yeah the professor and professors and
each other if there are multiple ones
the students in each other and the
students and professors yep now largely
these were treated i think
because we are all now
raised in the market and we face an
awful lot of end user license agreements
in most cases people write whatever into
them and people sign them without
thinking and probably never read them
and all of that but
that if you know i used to say in mine
this is not an end user license
agreement the expectation is that you
will read it because it's important
and i think the point is whatever the
opposite of an end user license
agreement is an end user license
agreement being an agreement that is
designed that you have to sign it and
will not read it and if you do read it
will not understand it
whatever the opposite of that is that is
to say an agreement that you are
expected to read so that you will adhere
to it
a functional organization needs one and
it has to include things about for
example the obligation to challenge
because the problem with uh the scenario
outlined in the question is if we make
rules against stigmatizing people for
example how do you not run a foul of
that rule in challenging somebody on the
basis that they've said something that
to you
seems incorrect yeah
so in order to avoid that what you have
to do is come up with an agreement in
spirit
that the idea is stigmatization should
not be used as a tool to rise in the
organization and so if somebody starts
to use this tool that it becomes
reputationally damaging to them having
done it because everybody will say
didn't we all agree not to do that
yeah
yeah it's it's a question of initial
conditions
and and buy-in
right the combination of initial
conditions and buy-in to those initial
conditions it's a question of buy-in
and so what that suggests is that the
agreement at the door
needs to be spelled out in terms
that explain why it is
that you benefit from
surrendering the ability to do x y or z
why would you not want the ability to
stigmatize somebody else well obviously
because you don't want that wielded
against you and because the organization
is best off if people are liberated to
challenge each other
so
anyway i think that's the basic answer
is we need a world in which we have very
clear and well thought out agreements at
the door some mechanism for modifying
them and a thorough understanding of why
these agreements serve us in the
aggregate so that people will defend
them right
exactly um
so i don't know what is going on with my
computer and the internet um
it seems like a common theme i don't
know what is going on with my computer
on the internet
here at dark horse but um
i was looking throughout most of your
answer and so was not paying his full
attention to what you were saying as i
might have been we got asked uh
something that wasn't exactly this but
it also prompted us to talk about these
covenants a while back and um
and so i posted
the covenant for the last program that
you and i did together for the year-long
study abroad program in which we took
students to ecuador for 11 weeks
on medium which um you know i'm not i'm
zach you can put this up here um
i'm not adding to medium at this point
because i'm putting all my stuff on
substance now
but this has this will have in it
a description of exactly what you were
talking about
uh and yeah this covenant is not an end
use like end user license agreement
right there yep
so
uh
yeah like that
okay
next
question
i'm not totally sure what this one means
but i'm gonna ask it anyway all right
you are both my favorite non-pregnant
non-mainstream media people
now why the big push for some sort of
rna medical technology does this make
sense in any treatment situation please
explain for the non-scientists in the
room
aka me
all right i get it okay um yeah this is
potentially
an extremely useful technology so
if you think about the
problem of a person who has a gene that
is defective so there are a lot of
mutations we call loss of function
mutations right you take a gene that
creates a protein that has some very
specific shape that's necessary to its
functioning and you move you remove an
amino acid or you change what amino acid
it is and that changes an
electromagnetic charge and causes the
thing to be just slightly misshapen so
it doesn't work and now the person has
some disease right
the point is well in theory if you know
with that description
the obvious answer to fixing this is
well can we edit the gene or can we
get the cell to produce
the product that we want it to produce
and
the problem is one of scale which is
that you're talking about a huge number
of cells that are involved in the
production of whatever that product is
and so the problem for gene therapy is
like yes in you know
the textbook diagram we know how to cure
your disease right but how do we in
practice given how many cells you're
composed of and how many of them need to
be producing this and what regulatory
mechanism do you need to get it to be
done at the right level how do we in
practice do it and so
what you can see in the rna vaccines
that were produced is the ability to
sort of sidestep the nucleus
to put a message a messenger rna into
the cytoplasm of the cell and get the
cell to produce the product that you
want which in this case was the spike
protein a very stupidly chosen product
but nonetheless if spike protein was
good for the system by virtue of let's
say in forming the immune system then
getting spike protein produced by the
cell is cool
the design of these things was to have
an anchor domain that would hold the
spike protein in the surface of the cell
so they would basically be displayed to
the immune system it's a cool design
didn't work but nonetheless the idea was
right yeah elegant idea
elegant idea so anyway we got a failed
prototype is what we've got but the
basic idea of hey let's get the cells to
produce these things is pretty good now
i think we can see
one of the obstacles here
in the question of dosing right because
in order to get this system to work
correctly there's some optimal amount of
spike protein you want displayed on the
surface of cells in order to get the
immunity that's useful right right the
problem is when you inject this stuff
into the arm
right you don't know how many cells and
of what type are going to take up the
mrna so in order for the person who has
especially if the anchoring isn't
working perfectly right so
effectively what i think happened is
in order to get
most people who got injected
to get sufficient immunity out of it
you've got to kind of overwhelm the
system so that the worst case where this
stuff just doesn't get taken up very
well is still good enough that means
that the people that it got taken up by
really well
were way overdosed on this stuff right
um so
and i mean and this in fact is
to my understanding
one of the if not the main difference
between the fizer and modern uh is one
of dosing yes uh and
uh it is
likely
largely explanatory in terms of why
moderna is the one that um scandinavian
countries for instance are
stopping
either stopping use of entirely or
saying people under 30 or specifically
males under 30 shouldn't be using you
know why not pfizer well pfizer is a
lower enough dose that the same risks of
for instance myocarditis are not being
seen in the same numbers
with pfizer because pfizer is a lower
dose but otherwise a very similar
product right
but anyway the answer the question the
person has asked here is that the
ability to get
the cells of a person to produce a
product that they are not already
producing has potential use and the
borrowing of it for vaccines is only one
potential use the use in terms of a gene
therapy where somebody's got a defective
gene
results in some tissue of theirs failing
to produce some useful product
what you really want to do is just be
able to get the cells to produce the
product that they should and an mrna
instruction that can be delivered to the
cytoplasm of the cell is one way to get
you know think about the alternative is
the alternative oh we could give you
the enzyme that you're failing to
produce well how yeah right you're going
to swallow it is it going to make it
through your gut wall you know how how
it works yeah i have a question for you
yeah we haven't talked about this i'm
not totally sure what you're going to
say actually i'm not sure what you're
going to say i think i know what my
answer is
uh if
let's call it pfizer moderna has an
additional uh problem uh in that its
only product
is the code vaccine
which means it absolutely needs to
survive for the company to survive which
which just makes obvious some of the
financial incentives
pfizer of course is a diverse
is a drug company with a lot of products
so
if pfizer came up with and we know that
that people are trying to do this
a malaria vaccine which of course has
been in high demand for decades and we
have wished for one we've been on all
sorts of crazy prophylaxis um some of
which was not particularly good for us
against malaria when we have um traveled
in places where malaria is endemic
especially falcipro malaria which is the
stuff that'll go cerebral and kill you
um
if pfizer were to produce an mrna
vaccine for malaria
how would you feel about that
how would you feel about um and yeah
obviously there's two there's too much
black box here we don't know
a lot but uh i mean it it depends
i i am
unclear on why in this case i mean i
guess i know the answer which is in this
case this case this hypothetical case
that i've just now in the case of the
mrna vaccines for covid
you know there's a question you're
trying to get the immune system to
scrutinize
antigens so that it comes up with the
formula to stick to them and then
remembers it okay that's the trick why
not just inject the antigen well in this
case you sure wouldn't want to right
spike protein is bad and it's not
supposed to be free floating so the idea
is well if the cells produce it and it
anchors then the point is the immune
system gets to see it without it
circulating right
at some it sounds like what you're
saying is
if a traditional vaccine isn't a good
idea why do we think this is a good idea
so and i don't think in the case of
malaria it's not that a traditional
vaccine is a good idea i don't know what
all the problems are but it's not for
lack of effort that we don't have a
malaria vaccine there have been many
many many attempts and some that seemed
like they were there and i just i don't
know the history except to know that you
know every single time i or we were
going someplace that were quite that was
in which
particularly falciparum but even vivec's
malaria was endemic uh you know went and
looked went like still no okay what's
you know what kind of prophylaxis is
available now
yeah i'm not sure i'm not sure what the
answer is it may have to do with the
exposure of the pathogen in action
to the immune system in other words if
it's inside of cells is it invisible
because the cells are
you know especially
red blood cells
[Music]
so it could be something like that
i guess you know i think we all now know
if we're paying attention and we're not
uh going to be overly responsive to the
threats that we're not allowed to talk
about the possible hazards with these
things yeah the real question is
does it work
what does work mean
is it going to make the problem worse in
the long term are there hazards that we
haven't talked about that are going to
emerge later that we should have been
cautious about but we're enthusiastic
because hey we had a product and that's
hard enough to find so
you know but is there
the are there a set of answers to those
questions
that would render you enthusiastic about
an mrna vaccine against malaria
yeah
but
you know frankly
you know if i was in the position to
write the rules i would take the people
who manufacture these things out of the
position of testing them right
of course right and i would say look
we've got a corruption problem right
your fda your cdc
and
by extension the who and everything that
looks like this
has to be immunized from corruption
whatever that means and if it isn't
immunized from corruption then you know
you're going to need a whole shaker of
grains of salt for all of the things
that are handed down because you don't
know when what you're looking at is
actually a sales pitch dressed up as
science and when it's actually science
so you know could you convince me of an
mrna solution to the malaria problem you
absolutely could but you couldn't do it
quickly on the basis of hey this paper
says it's 97 successful because you know
97 successful could mean anything yeah
so at some level uh
one thing that you've said there is not
just should r d
and marketing publicity be different you
know have a firewall between them but
maybe r and d should as well if if d is
in part the testing if research is is
well no
i don't even know i don't even know what
r d is separate right but if uh if if
development of if insight into what the
thing is and development of it is is one
thing um then assessing
uh assessing assessing safety and
efficacy should be some different
these things different group yeah have
to be firewalled and the firewalls have
to be dynamic if you build a firewall
and you say it's good enough then the
point is they're going to be leaks
things are going to find their way
through and they're going to enlarge
those leaks over time and you know
it
the entire dysfunction of our system is
downstream of the corruption
right it's not always called corruption
we've got a thousand different names
from it for it you know it's influence
peddling of one sort or another but
there are lots of ways to do that in
which a court of law can't figure out
what's happened and so it's quasi-legal
but the answer is look
you know just as we discussed with the
question of
agreements at the front door of an
organization
we all have to agree that the corruption
of our governmental structure is the
most devastating thing that can happen
to us right we we are badly wired for
this right we're wired to pay attention
to things like serial killers and
airline crashes and not pay attention at
all to the mundane boring and strange
abductions right and the fact is that's
not
you know plane crashes kill
hundreds of people at a time right
they're very fascinating because we've
all ridden on planes and we can imagine
what you would think as you descend and
all of that but
you want to know what kills people bad
policy and you know what makes bad
policy corruption right corruption is
the thing that prevents you from seeing
the hazards it prevents you from seeing
the perverse incentives it prevents you
from seeing that you have a better
option corruption is the problem and
um
the problem is most people
you know i talk even even our smartest
group
right the people that we circulate among
who are capable of doing the analysis of
the really difficult stuff
almost everybody's under focused on
corruption
it's just not interesting
yeah
um
it's not interesting and it's hard to
track and i think
so you you may read what i'm about to
say as being under focused on corruption
but as you were talking before you said
that
i was thinking there's an analogy
uh to what people imagine the dangers
are when you go to the rain forest when
you go to the jungle and there the
problem is never corruption right um
almost never very occasionally we've
been in a situation where there's you
know there's drilling or something and
uh
and there's a safety issue because of
the human activities in the area
put that aside
and
in the situation that you were relaying
the problem is almost always corruption
people don't focus on it but also it is
true that of course we focus on the
charismatic one-off event that is
constrained in space and time yeah right
and so people imagine when before they
go to the jungle that it's about the
snakes and the big cats right you know
the you know the stuff that's you know
the stuff that's fierce and gonna come
at you and you can imagine and it's
terrifying
and
you know stakes exist and big cats exist
and uh people have died from wrangling
with them um but the far bigger dangers
in the rain forest
are from things uh like
uh rains that cause rivers to rise um
you know fast as we talk about
introduction to our book but more often
in the act like in the amazon slowly
such that you walked across a trail and
when you come back to it a couple hours
later it's unrecognizable and you can't
figure out where you are and now you're
lost and you never find your way back um
and tree falls tree falls every false
i've almost been killed twice by tree
falls i've never had i've seen plenty of
highly poisonous snacks and never once
had a run-in i've been struck at once by
poisonous snake on first what was
perhaps my worst day ever in the field
which is a story i haven't even written
down i will tell at some point perhaps
but it was one of like eight terrible
things that happened that day but um
but that and but i've i've even stepped
on on one other um
bushmaster actually and it just kind of
looked at me it's like okay i'm out i'm
i'm leaving now yeah um
you don't mean bushmaster you mean fair
to lance and the amazon i'm i think it
was a
push master
you don't think so i don't think so um
but anyway we know one person who has
been envenomated
by
a
fair delance
had a pretty rough in central america
yeah
but she survived it
but the point is yeah if you focus on
the snakes and uh
i don't know some people worry about
cats other people wouldn't but um
but if you focus on that stuff you'll
miss the success right you're like oh
i'm gonna go out there alone at night
and i'm gonna you know maybe i'll be
stalked by a panthers like well you
would that you were so lucky at some
level you know right um because you know
it's especially if you're with someone
and there's no there's no way a cat like
that is going to attack you for one
thing the uh
people who have lived in the area have
killed whenever animals came after
humans and so the animals have a
irrational fear of humans but um
but anyway yeah if you focus on the
stuff that you think is gonna kill you
you're leaving yourself vulnerable to
the stuff that's actually likely to
which is shallowly rooted trees um
water that does things you don't predict
that just
radically changes the landscape that you
were just in and so you assume you know
it and so this is it's you know it's
beyond the sort of
uh
backcountry backpacking advice of you
know look behind you on the trail so
that you see how different it looks in
the direction that you're going to be
coming back at it from you know the
water the water level changes can change
the water level can change so fast that
the landscape just is radically
different yeah regardless of whether or
not you're coming in the same direction
or not the other one which you and i
have never
uh had a run in with but that is a
surprising hazard is actually exposure
right because you think it's hot
you know i don't need to worry about
hypothermia but that is a very different
puzzle when it's raining and you're
losing all of this heat to water which
absorbs a ton of heat from you and you
didn't prepare for it and so you you
know you can't maintain a boundary layer
that actually threatens people more than
you would imagine or you know
it's somewhere in between because people
actually do fear bees and they should uh
you know in the wrong circumstances
africanized bees can be um quite
dangerous
yeah um but
now they really can
all right um
i am
not me question i am pregnant and
unvaxed
thank you for prefacing that
you said not me
this is a hell of a way to discover that
you're going to have another child so
i'm pregnant and vaxxed hubby had
covered 10 days fever and cough i never
got it from him my blood work shows no
antibodies should i feel confident i
won't get it next time exposed
no no
no you haven't told us if you
self-isolated when he had it if you
didn't you should feel a little more
confident but if you don't have
antibodies well i think you have a
tiny bit of evidence that you know it's
not strong evidence but you have a tiny
bit of evidence that you are a little
bit resistant to contracting it which
could be for lots of reasons it could be
that your vitamin d levels are good or
they were at the time it could be that
you know you have type o blood it's just
gonna say yeah your blood your blood is
uh less sticky less likely to
clot and therefore but
but but if you were exposed you know
still why wouldn't you have the
antibodies well no i okay so let me give
you my
course understanding of this first of
all i don't think you'd be likely to
have the antibodies if exposed without
contracting it
okay that the building of a robust set
of memory cells that creates antibodies
is downstream of infection but it is not
automatically downstream i think that's
right but i guess i wouldn't i wouldn't
have thought that your blood type would
therefore have been protective in
advance of being infected
[Music]
i think it's protective just for
arbitrary reasons that you've got a
pathogen adapted to certain environments
and less adapted to other environments
and it happens that type o blood if i'm
remembering this result correctly no
it's type o but i think you know some of
the thinking
i actually am not sure that this isn't
just my thinking um is that uh because
kovid and also the vaccines are
understood in part to be a clotting
disease right um that and i can't
remember if it's a or b but one of the
one of the blood types with a with a
thing that's sticking off your off your
blood cells um
is associated with worst outcomes from
kovid um and i think a b as well maybe
um and then o is associated with better
than average outcomes
and uh that that i i have i have sort of
internalized this folk understanding of
okay well this is about something about
the mechanism of action of cyrus kobe 2
being about
increasing clotting and if you have typo
blood you are somewhat more resistant to
clotting and somewhat more likely to
bleed out like that's the trade-off i
think you're you're conflating two
things one of them has to do with the
clotting and the outcomes that are the
result of the interaction of spike
protein and one has to do with
susceptibility
so you think there's something that we
haven't that we don't we don't know what
it is but there's some there's something
as yet unnamed about oh type o blood
that uh makes you less susceptible to
coven okay
it's possible right um but the other
point is this antibody thing is
somewhat of a red herring
because the immunity that you're looking
for is t cell immunity yeah and the
seroconversion of a person is an
antibody thing so basically the point is
did you get a good enough dose of sars
cov2 that you seroconverted if so you
probably have innate immunity or not at
night immunity yeah natural immunity
that is highly effective but really what
you're looking at is a proxy for the t
cells which we can't easily measure yeah
right
so um
the fact of not having antibodies
doesn't mean
that you didn't contract it it's
very tightly correlated with not having
contracted it but it's not perfect yeah
um and so i would say the short answer
to the question is no you can't be at
all sure that you're resistant and be
very very careful because you don't want
it um and also think about it you
definitely don't need i mean you
definitely don't want it when you're
pregnant you definitely don't want it
when you're pregnant the disease right
and so
i think we would advise anybody who is
um
going to be pregnant while
uh this disease is out there to probably
isolate much more than you might
otherwise do
because it's a dangerous disease
it is
informal fallacies are hard to spot
and fuel tribalism and conflict they
seem to pass brett's adaptation rubric
the uh
three or four part test of adaptation
we've called it both
um are these chesterton's fallacies or
do we understand their purpose well
enough to remove them can you go back to
the very first phrase informal fallacies
and hard to spot and fuel tribalism and
conflict
i think i think we need an example yeah
um i think we need an example or two
here
in order to know exactly how to respond
at least i do
it's too abstract yet
yeah i mean i come up with stuff yeah
you know like
the idea that if you
have flipped five heads in a row that
you're very likely to flip tails that's
a fallacy that people carry
um
another one there what was it
oh things
don't jump
but things like correlation does not
imply causation
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence right
these things oh the plural of anecdotes
is not data
right these are all things that contain
a truth in them but are not true
they are true under some circumstances
right so for example
correlation does imply causation when it
is downstream of a pre-existing
hypothesis that is causal and i just
simplify that correlation implies
causation when preceded by hypothesis
that there would be correlation yeah
right a causal hypothesis that
predicts causation for example
um you know extraordinary claims
are up against exactly the same
logical rubric as every other claim
right
the hypothesis has to best explain the
data and assume the least
and it doesn't matter how it's true i
mean you know plate tectonics is a hell
of a
a hell of a claim but um but the point
is is it the best hypothesis is it the
most explanatory hypothesis you have
well there you go um
and you know the plural of anecdote is
data depending on
whether or not it's truly comparable
right you could
you could look into a pool of anecdotes
and turn it into data um it is not
automatically data
but you know the question is what kind
of anecdotes are you talking about
this i think this one requires a little
bit more
a little bit more i would say i would
say it differently
i would say
and i'm reminded actually of barb smutz
who was on my dissertation committee
excellent behavioral ecologist and
baboon researcher
who whose work i used to use when i
would teach animal behavior and
her point in part was
often the things by which you learn the
most about especially a social organism
like baboons
happens so rarely that you'll only have
one or you know a couple of incidents
of of it in an entire giant data set
even if you spend years
and you can't do stats on one or a
couple of incidents
but you can know a tremendous amount if
you are absolutely certain that you saw
what you think you saw
so this is a different point but you
know i i will i will go to about 100 for
for this point that sometimes an
anecdote is actually evidence oh
anecdotes are evidence whether they are
data is a different question well so in
in the in the framework of doing animal
behavior where you are where you were
doing formal observations and you're out
there saying you've specified them and
do focal watches i'm going to do you
know this is how i'm taking data and
you're out there watching and a thing
happens
right uh you you can use that as
evidence about you know if you're say
you're trying to make an ethogram of you
know what all what is in the suite of
behaviors that this organism does
well this happens and you know say in
500 hours of observations this happened
once
and you know maybe that means it's
exactly that rare and maybe it means
that they don't do it in front of people
and maybe it means they only do it you
know in different populations where
we're not watching it you know you don't
know what it what the rarity means
necessarily
but what you do know is sometimes that
thing happens
right yeah
i mean
the point you're making is
much more important than the one i'm
trying to make but it's different right
the point you're making and i you know
this one is
dead certain
is
anecdotes
constitute a valid part of scientific
thinking right the observation that
leads to a hypothesis that then leads to
a proper test is very frequently
anecdotal right and there's nothing
there is no violation of the scientific
method in that but i would so to use
this you know again this animal behavior
example if you are
if you have predicted that you will see
call it
you know war between competing tribes of
chimps right to move from baboons to
champs and to identify a thing that jane
goodall saw
i don't actually remember that story
well enough to know if she predicted it
would happen
if she predicted war in advance i think
i think she wasn't really doing that
kind of work but you but she could have
in which case having observed it if she
had carefully
described in advance what would have
constituted war had she seen it then
that single observation would have been
a test of the hypothesis yeah that's a
that's a good point too it's you know
yes it it's arguably an anecdote um a
war is an anecdote but the point is it
is an unambiguous
uh description of something
all right fair enough
let's see that's the one we just did
um
would you do a talk with scott adams
there seems to be a game of telephone
going on between your audiences over
jabs and variants and hypermectin that a
more direct exchange might fix
also check out his three plus one model
from today's stream
uh i consider it you know he and i have
a lot of disagreements but i also see a
lot of value in what he does
yeah
maybe
uh i read
i read that there can be some natural
immunity to covet 19 that occurs from
being infected by similar less virulent
coronaviruses like cow pox smallpox
what's your take on that
um not just
cowbox smallpox which i actually didn't
know i don't know
i'm not sure that that is true um but um
but common cold yeah common cold viruses
uh there is a paper
or two maybe i can't remember out
recently um that precisely show show
that um that previous exposure to some
some
at least other coronaviruses including
the ones that circulate a lot um and
that we then once were infected called
the common cold uh do provide
um some immunity from sorry scoby too
yeah cross reactivity yeah
yes
i absolutely can't stand when a flyer
mosquito buzzes around my head or lands
on me
my mom however loves the feel of flies
on her skin whoa never heard this before
nope
might there be a trade-off to explain
this
well
first i'd have to know if your mother is
simply the only human being in existence
who feels this way because i've
literally never run into anyone else who
said this i would have formulated it
differently but i had the same
hypothesis
that there is that this is just a
totally one-off your mom's just weird
yeah my mom no
i mean
yes or no jesse
um yeah that's uh that's weird
yeah that is weird and i mean in part
well you know mosquitoes we know vector
things and some flies vector things too
yeah there's a reason
you know there there are adaptive
reasons that we don't like having these
things around us which is to say that
although in north america at this point
most of the flying dipterans because
mosquitoes are flies and that's the
that's the group that's the clade
diptera um
don't vector anything any of them i
wouldn't say this because
if you think about
uh
watching your average house fly
right which is interesting actually oh
yeah fascinating critter yeah um but the
house fly that lands on the rim of your
drink may just have been investigating
some dog [ __ ] in the neighboring yard
and so there ain't no getting around
that because the vectoring doesn't
involve it parasitizing yeah it's just
potentially moving other pathogens
around right now i will tell you
this is my long-standing hypothesis for
the salt on the rim of margaritas
because it's actually it's if a
bacterium yeah eating out eating outside
in the places where margaritas evolved
right as it were why hasn't there's lots
of glass and that glass has a ton of
salt on it then the point is the
bacterium will die
right and not infect you so there are
other little behaviors that sugared too
actually for other drinks you're right
it's less effective but still will be
effective yeah i mean jam you know jam
works
high sugar concentrations and jam works
as a preserving
agent but for the same reason because
the water will migrate out of the the
pathogen
but we also see other technologies
employed in the same kinds of places
it's very frequent in a tropical place
if you get a drink with a straw for them
to leave the paper on the very end of
the straw
right or if you get something in a
bottle with a cap they will often leave
the cap
they'll open it yeah open not screw top
they'll open it for you but then hand it
to you with the cap still um loosely on
right so anyway i would argue all these
things are the same
most delightfully done with respect to
margaritas and i guess lemon drops but
uh
um
but yeah yeah it would explain it
wouldn't it
yeah um also yeah your mom is weird i
think that's the answer okay on that one
right yeah
all right in order to cover ourselves
here i think we're gonna need to put out
a shirt that says all moms are weird
that way our moms won't feel singled out
really
no i didn't i wasn't saying you're i was
saying the person asked the question oh
okay your mom's definitely weird well
see now you've done it
yeah but unlike my mom she doesn't watch
she'll never i think she does i think
she doesn't want the q a yeah okay
um oh speak dear mom
i'm excited to hear that you are working
on a science fiction novel
if you manage to get it published in a
higher order dimension would you
consider it to be
hyper novel
nicely done
yes a hyper novel
a hyper novel and related ish although
i'm not going to be able to answer this
you may be able to start answering this
such that i am spurred to to remembering
um
since heather doesn't like a lot of the
biology and science fiction could she
describe where she thinks the classics
fall short and then the three examples
that he gives are e.t alien and star
wars
well first of all it's not just heather
that doesn't like the biology and
science fiction yeah or both thoroughly
of course i've just talked about it as
you know this is part of what was uh
part of what i've always wanted to to do
in science fiction of my own is to is to
write
is to have science fiction it's
compelling biologically i'm gonna
i'm gonna step back for a moment and say
um
there if if you have friends who are
biologists you will be familiar with the
irritating thing that happens when
uh you watch say badly done nature
documentaries or
if you do this with your friends disney
movies for instance uh and they
are constantly yelling at the television
and saying that's ah that's that story
they just gave isn't right or that
doesn't belong there or any movies
really like oh they're in the jungle why
are there loons like why are they
playing loon noises right
and uh i
was recently inspired never having done
so not being a fan of disney movies for
precisely the reason that we're talking
about
i recently watched with our younger son
while you were
traveling with zach to watch the lion
king which i had never seen actually
following our conversation with jordan
peterson
and i actually you know there's a lot to
say about i'm not going to say most of
it here now but i actually very much
enjoyed it but at the very beginning of
the movie uh and i almost turned it off
at the very beginning of the movie
they they did one of these things that
that disney just seems that that many
animated movies seem to just feel very
comfortable doing where you know it's
all these african animals and of course
there's lots of you know it's all
anthropomorphized and you you can't get
you can't get worried about that in that
movie but they've got zebras and they've
got lions and they've got warthogs and
hyenas and then they got this close-up
of leafcutter ants like there aren't any
leafcutter ants in africa
but why why why do it there's plenty of
exciting stuff in africa to show you
don't have to import
latin american you know neotropical ants
into africa in order to make your movie
more robust it was totally unnecessary
so i groaned and our 15 year old is like
what what now what did they get wrong
i'm like well toby you've seen
leafcutter ants in their native habitat
you've seen them in the amazon they
aren't in africa
anyway it's it's that sort of kind of
objection um of okay
takes take particulars of what have what
has evolved on earth and then assume
that the particulars are what's going to
be happening elsewhere no
right it's it's natural selection will
have happened elsewhere and sexual
selection will have happened elsewhere
but why do we assume any of the other
particulars um largely when it's when
it's movies when it's television it's
because we have human actors and so it's
just it's easier to assume bipedal forms
with eyes in the same place but there's
um otherwise not a lot of reason to
expect those forms yeah there's a lot of
i mean you know
the sexy alien
right that's a really dumb trope yeah
yes
but you know yeah there's a lot of
you know even the aliens yeah the
possibility of hybridizing with aliens
sorry no not going to happen right i
mean and unless you've got a backstory
that has their you know their origin and
spermia or something like that exactly
but but even then other than that no but
even even then panspermia doesn't get
you there because uh humans evolved here
late yeah um yeah so
yeah there's there is some backstory
that could make it work but it has to be
really complex it has to it then
violates all sorts of stuff that is
central to science and so it has to be
explicit it can't it can't be tangential
yeah i mean i guess i mean just like in
any fantasy um or science fiction like
you know
make the cognitive dissonance make the
the
the leap that we have to make
tidy enough and have it fed all in one
place all in one nugget be like okay
this thing is what you're going to where
you're going to have to suspend your
disbelief
and then you're not going to have to
continue to do it you're not going to
keep on running into logical fallacies
or evolutionary fallacies over and over
and over again allow me to tell me where
i'm gonna have to suspend my disbelief
let me do it once you know maybe a
couple times but once
never well
let me go like once maybe a couple of
times if there's reason to introduce
something later that is you know
especially if it's contingent on that
first one but you know maybe you're now
in a different place
but make it clear that the author is in
a relationship with the reader that
they're not just assuming that you're
just going to continue to suspend your
disbelief well
okay so my point about the suspension of
disbelief is that it's one thing to add
particulars right in harry potter you
can add new spells but the idea that you
are in a place where spells are a thing
is up front right yeah and so you are
not
the the problem is the narrative that
causes the suspension of disbelief to
jump right
you believed at some level and then they
cause you to jump again and jump again
and it destroys the the nature of it
rather than
you know this is a this is a land where
right this is a land where works fine i
guess um too often i see
situations in which
the author doesn't even seem to
recognize that they are doing it that
they are actually breaking yeah um rules
um of of natural selection of evolution
whatever and so at that point uh you
know i don't
i'm not interested in reading because i
don't feel like i'm in the hands of
someone who's capable of telling an
interesting story uh because because if
that's broken who knows who knows what
else is broken yep
um yeah with regard to e.t alien and
star wars
i mean i've
seen all of them but i can't remember
i never saw e.t
how did you manage to grow up when you
did without seeing e.t
not sure yeah not sure okay um i don't
know i would say
you know is that is an alien likely to
be able to ride a bicycle or was he not
riding the bicycle was it the kid you
don't know i don't know you don't know i
think the kid must have been riding the
bicycle but you know let's put it this
way alien
e.t
and star wars
well star wars is just like a biblical
soap opera in space with a cool bar in
which they hint it
yeah star wars isn't isn't trying to
it's not it's it's like it's like a
backdrop for a very
conventional earthly story sorry i know
i just pissed everyone off but
um
the
you know e.t
but it's epic i mean it's it's it's epic
in a in a new place but it doesn't
it doesn't pretend to be
accurate i mean like you know the bar
that you point out like they're all
they're all humanoid well not all of you
know but almost they stretched for that
right little
it little but not little but a bunch of
them are sexy aliens et is also not
enough of a stretch yeah right he's
right you know he's two eyes bipedal
he's diminutive
but the point is not enough you know
they played with the llama tree they're
like let's lengthen the arms right right
and you know
we were making the i can't remember
where it was we were making the
comparison
yesterday or the day before you know
between
deer and kangaroos right like that's not
even a big evolutionary
gap these are two different versions of
you know a mammal or before
right and the point is actually they're
very different yeah right and so the
point is okay if that difference accrues
in you know the short period of
evolutionary history between
uh the ancestors of of macropods and the
ancestors of of servids
what kind of amazing differences might
well exist between
sentient aliens and humans and the
answer is most authors just aren't up to
imagining
a
how big a gap that is and given such a
gap what would likely be relatable right
yeah and so you know there was one
episode of star trek i don't even
particularly like the substrate but
there was an episode with a molten
creature
right it was like a molten lava creature
but it obviously
could be communicated with it was
clearly a creature
right and like okay molten that's out of
the question presumably but um
but nonetheless it was a big gap that
didn't look like any earth creature yeah
and
you know people need to be thinking at
that level of distinction yeah totally
yeah and i i probably shouldn't say this
because i don't remember the name of the
book nor do i remember enough of the
specifics but i just read a science
fiction novel that started out really
strong and has won all these awards
a chinese author and just about halfway
through sort of decayed into one of
these errors like oh
but the civilization wouldn't come back
the same way every time like why
that's not how it would work right and i
did end up finishing it off and i would
just say okay i'm done then you know
sort of
sunk costs with novels i i read the
whole thing and was more and more
disappointed as i went on because i
thought well i i trusted this author to
be able to teach me something some
interesting things about how such a
world might work and now i don't
okay
uh what is the evolutionary perspective
on inbreeding
well the evolutionary perspective on
inbreeding is one of two things there's
sort of a conventional one which is
inbreeding bad
in breeding bad because
there are
a gene that is recessive can be very
very bad for you if it's at low enough
frequency in the population
because it's very unlikely to encounter
another like it and therefore most
people who have it suffer no consequence
but if you mate with a close relative
the likelihood that you have inherited
two copies of a bad recessive gene from
the same ancestor or that your offspring
will is very very high and so
effectively it is estimated that human
beings carry on average something like
eight of these lethal deleterious
recessives and therefore if you mate
with somebody
closer than a first cousin the chances
of one of these things emerging is
uh
quite what is substantially
degrading of the uh
quality of the offspring so
the problem is
inbreeding bad is not good enough
because lots of creatures have endured
substantial inbreeding out of necessity
so
breeding presumably happens every time a
tiny population is isolated and that is
often the origin story for a major
successful new species so
obviously it can't be that bad
um
also we've had lots of creatures hunted
to near extinction uh so you know sea
otters were down to a population i
believe of less than 100 same thing can
be said for northern elephant seals
cheetahs have gotten low but not that
low and the thing that does not get said
frequently enough
is that as populations get small and
inbreeding goes up the visibility of
deleterious recessives to selection also
goes up and so its ability to purge
those things goes up so the point is
inbreeding is very bad at first and gets
less bad over time
um
so like that i would say that's the
better
more nuanced perspective yeah very
good um
do you know have you ever heard of
havana syndrome
um
i have not the question is could a fana
syndrome which causes migraines and
brain damage be caused by crickets
and then there's a link to a article in
the independent uk paper
i don't know what havana syndrome is nor
do i know if it could be caused by
crickets
well i'm just gonna
riff here based on no knowledge
whatsoever
there is something very bad about
noise that you have to process that does
not have content
right we think we get away with it
that is just annoying but there's a
reason that it's annoying and the
annoyingness probably has to do with the
wearing out of the hearing apparatus you
know so the
loss of flexibility of the hairs and the
cochlea
the processing of
random information
is bad and i think there was some recent
study
i didn't actually look at it but i
heard that it existed about the
hazard
to cognition late in life from living
near i think it was railroads and
and highways the noise basically
um
using up
mental reserve capacity interesting
so
my guess would be something like
crickets we would have a very good
algorithm for filtering out
at low cost right it's you know in our
book we talk about the distinction
between the hazard pose to a human by
co2 which we
make ourselves and
carbon monoxide which we don't
basically we don't have a detector for
carbon monoxide because
our the hazard is new
and co2 the hazard is ancient and so the
point is we're very effective at dealing
with the the risk of co2
i would imagine we're very effective at
dealing with the risk of crickets
and we may not be as good at dealing
with the risk of trains right for the
same same reason yeah um i clicked
through on the link but it requires that
i register which i'm not going to do
right now
um so i don't know if you are
thinking in a mechanism that's
completely unrelated to what they're
saying or or not okay don't know
we've been at it for
about 55 minutes so let's get through
just a few more real quickly
i think the answer is going to be no
here but i'll read it i have an idea for
election reform in the spirit of your
2020 uh dark horse proposal unity
can you recommend any people or groups
to contact regarding putting an
initiative on the oregon ballot
jesus
i just don't have any connections i know
there's some
mechanism but basically
uh yeah i don't think we're in a good
position to say yeah
uh can you expand on ways on the ways
that craftsmanship craftsmanship sorry
can you expand on the ways that
craftsmanship can simulate growth and be
economically viable as you described in
the fourth frontier chapter also any
thoughts on d growth
thanks uh so we talk
in the book about craftsmanship being a
way to sort of
have a sense of a feeling of growth
without actually requiring more
resources so you put more you put more
energy into building something that will
last and it will provide joy rather than
just functionality like you'll get from
uh from the ikea table that you that you
buy boxed and then put together um so
you know there's more to be said but
that's the basic idea
yeah i mean i would say there are a
number of things um
one there is the incentive to build
something that lasts a craftsman does
not have the same perverse incentive to
build something that you will buy and
then buy another version of later the
way ikea does
and so by
increasing the value
of the object rather than increasing the
saleability of the object or the use of
resources therefore that's the point it
uses resources once and it may use
somewhat more resources but the fact
that it uses the resources once and that
one continues to get joy out of it in a
way that one does not continue to get
joy out of a disposable piece of
furniture
or a you know
fiberboard cabinet or
whatever it is especially not once it's
actually landed in a landfill yeah so i
would just say you know it
it leans in the direction of
the same amount or more joy arising from
the same object
with a single uh purchase yeah
in a single creation
and you know the act of creation
actually provides joy as well whereas
presumably the active creation of an
ikea fiberboard cabinet provides no joy
to anyone well it also
um
you know we have these mechanisms that
produce huge amounts of stuff without
very many people having a
living wage coming out of it right so
you know if you think about the
comparison between
home depot and all of the hardware
stores that it replaced you know a
hardware store mom and pop might be able
to send a kid to college on a hardware
store income
and you know then
that gets converted into
yachts and third homes for the uh you
know the ceo and cfo of home depot and a
lot of workers who don't earn the kind
of wage that they can send a kid to
college
right so in some sense
the
craftsman earns much more of the profit
in the object that they produce and so
the point is that is actually like
growth through redistribution right
instead of having excess pile up
at the top yeah that's good
a hundred podcasts bravo why is lying so
prevalent in humans and in society can
we evolve past it thank you
um
two answers one
lying
let's start in a different place
you've got the truth whatever it may be
right and then the question is can you
spin it so it's even more effective at
doing your bidding right whatever the
truth may be maybe there's some way you
can present it that makes your version
of the truth just a little more saleable
so
this is truth plus
right if truth plus out competes truth
then where does this stop right right
presumably at some point the fact that a
truth is no longer even a close relative
of the truth right it's a fiction that
looks like a truth
when that gets discovered causes a big
uh contraction right in other words you
find somebody telling you something that
sounds like the truth and then it turns
out to have been [ __ ] and the point
is well i don't trust you anymore but
the problem is
in a world of
fungible currency
you may not know who lied to you and you
may therefore not be able to degrade
in your mind the trust that you might
have had in other things that they say
so they get away with it yeah and so
basically we have no enforcement
mechanism or very little enforcement
mechanism available to us in modern
times due to the hyper novelty which
means that the penalty for lying has
gone down and the competitive advantage
that comes from lying has presumably not
gone down maybe it's gone up maybe it's
been static but comparison between the
two
results in a world of [ __ ] 24 hours
a day seven days a week 365 days a year
takes no holidays this [ __ ] [ __ ]
takes no holidays
uh a happy hundredth episode here's to
100 more i just got your book excited to
read it if you're ever in new york city
would love to get your autographs
yes and we are hoping to actually maybe
do something on the road at some point
it's not going to be now it's not going
to be a standard book tour because
everything is chaos now maybe
again going places that presumably we've
been before mostly we'll have been there
before yeah but in some cases maybe not
yeah totally um but yes somewhere
yes indeed
uh let's see there are a couple more
that i wanted to get to uh this past
thursday was hannah arant's birthday has
the sars kobe 2 pandemic become a zoo
for observing the banality of evil
a bit you betcha mm-hmm
yeah
uh if trans men are men and trans women
are women why would anyone need to say
birthing person unless they don't
believe their own rhetoric
ah that's because they don't believe
they're better again frankly how could
they it's really not very high quality
rhetoric and so no the whole it's it's
really a dare
it is i dare you to point out that what
i'm saying is stupid because i'm
powerful and i will hurt you yes exactly
uh my new article clown world is
available on medium i hope it gives
people a way to laugh at the insanity
this is from a regular question asker
i'll fight you naked
i'll bet it's good clown world on medium
why is japan doing so well with regards
to kovid
is it related to ivermectin
you know
very
difficult to say if i remember has
anything to do with it yeah yeah
but it could there was something that
looked like maybe
there was there was widespread adoption
but maybe that those reports are suspect
right but i mean i would say there's
such a wide variance in how well places
are
doing it may have to do with policy it
may have to do with culture and the way
people interact normally being
you know less
uh conducive to passing the pathogen it
may have to do with health and well so
health is one thing you know you don't
you don't have the epidemic of obesity
in japan that you do for instance in the
u.s and we know that obesity is one of
the major comorbidities for covid um
there also may be other things like
blood type like a blood type varies by
geographical reason
region and i don't remember
what blood type is dominant in japan
but there may be other things beyond
blood type
that are distributed whether or not
they're genetic or not but that have to
do with underlying anatomical and
physiological realities that make some
populations less or more susceptible yep
i'd be curious about vitamin d intake
given that
japan has a
very different traditional cuisine than
uh yeah mainland asia it's not gonna be
environmental they're pretty far north
although
you know a lot of ocean
access
um
yeah
yep don't know i don't know don't
know
uh let's see i was gonna read at least
one
more
oh i don't know the answer to this what
are your thoughts on supplementing with
whey protein could it be dangerous
um
no idea
i mean i think it
it depends on
who the source
is what altitude it was growing growing
on it so you know my way
or highway
sorry of course you did
of course of course you did all right um
i mean the fact is you would also have
to compare
uh
you would want a proper control
no way
so i wasn't actually trying to ignore
you by looking at my phone which i never
do you never do what i what i did here
was apparently some of the questions
weren't coming in and so i asked uh our
moderator to um send me any questions
via text i told them that i would leave
the phone on
um but i've only got one so far so uh
let's finish with
this one we're at over an hour right
zach yes we are
do you have any thoughts that you can
share regarding the merck and pfizer
anti-viral pills that have been in the
news lately
do we have any what that we can share
thoughts oh thoughts yes
um yeah absolutely
you know a
i don't think
especially with respect to malnu piravir
that the a lot of people have said
it's ivermectin dressed up to look new
yeah it's not um it has a relationship
but the important thing there's a there
is at least one molecular mechanism of
action or uh a a like a a group on it
like a molecular group on it that is
similar i can't remember what it is but
there's some it works when you say
there's a relationship you don't mean
that they're like
everybody i mean they're broken down and
they're not completely distinct in terms
of their mechanism of action but malnu
piravir
introduces these we talked about this a
little bit on a past podcast yeah it
introduces these um
uh deformed
nucleotides yes which causes dysfunction
and yes interferes with viral
replication that's all well and good
but it is not
disrupting
the rna of
the virus specifically so it will also
[Music]
it will also certainly disrupt as
you are now saying here you know here's
here's a reason to be suspect of it as
far as we know ivermectin does not
disrupt do anything of this right
in this way and so the point is it is
not introducing the equivalent of
mutations that disrupt the function of
the virus but yes also the function of
the cell it's functioning through
another mechanism so i guess the basic
point is
you better believe that we should be on
our guard with respect to
the harm done by the drug to normal
cellular function yes right and so in
effect there's a thing that gets said
about chemotherapy
right so
this is not chemotherapy but there's an
analogy here yeah the thing about
chemotherapy is chemotherapy is
cytotoxic
right it works against cancer cells
better than regular cells because cancer
cells are chronically in a dividing
state which makes them vulnerable so it
makes them cancer
right but but what people
say with respect to chemotherapy is that
the idea is to kill the cancer faster
than you kill the patient right it's a
relative rate problem right killing the
patient is not a good thing killing the
you know killing the cancer faster than
you kill the patient is an acceptable
thing to do when somebody has a
potentially fatal disease
so
the point here is
you know that you're going to be
disrupting normal cellular function and
you know that you're going to be
disrupting viral function and yes
there's a relative rate question can you
disrupt the virus for a short period of
time at a high enough rate that the
damage you do to regular cells is
tolerable i guess
but well if it clears right no
if you didn't have a better alternative
that's the question so the fact that
that's a better question but it's also
true that the relative rate
uh question
only works the way that you said so if
it terminates if you know it clears the
system and then it doesn't continue to
act and you know okay well the virus is
gone
maybe it still continues to act on
normal cells well right but ultimately
it will clear whether it kills off the
cells ultimately but you can't just do a
you know timed virus clearance
um
question a comparison if you don't know
how fast how long it takes before the
drug itself and let's put it this way
you'd have to be a [ __ ] dimwit to do
it if you had an alternative that didn't
have this defect and you'd have to be a
freaking monster to suppress information
about the alternative if the alternative
was comparatively harmless right so and
so the original question which i guess i
already checked on so i don't oh
actually we're gonna ask we're gonna do
one more question of this that's the one
i was looking for um
mentioned both merck and pfizer and i
don't um so
malnu pil piravir malnu pirovir is the
mark one um i
kind of know that pfizer has one but i
don't know what it is or anything about
it um
i know less about it which is why i'm
not okay i'm gonna speak on it until i
do okay
were you done talking about that all
right one last question and then we will
sign off for the week it is puffball
season here in iowa
do you folks mushroom hunt and if so
what are your favorites also any cool
mushroom photos to share well i would
say
it's not that simple
we engage in hunt and release
with the mushrooms
and
you know presumably they go on to live
full
healthy lives
in
the forest um
[Laughter]
yeah we do not mushroom we have we can
hunt anyway i mean it's hard it's it's
hard to know with them because yeah i
will say
uh we dig mushrooms
we
have a healthy respect for
um the possibility of getting the wrong
kind of mushroom having a devastating
effect on you and so
uh i'm you know there are certain
mushrooms that are a slam dunk that you
can recognize right like chanterelles
uh or bowlets or um
i think i saw somebody hunting um
morels yesterday really yeah in the
cemetery i wasn't 100 sure but
anyway
not against it would certainly do it but
we have not um we have not engaged in it
systematically yeah
we thought we might start when we moved
to the pacific northwest now gosh
19 years ago yeah ended a little bit
and i've
i've ended up engaging in a little
picking of mushrooms in other places of
different types
but
i was talking to zach about uh kakadu
vodka
yeah yeah that was it that was the one
that was it uh in fact i was writing
about the little bit for the sub step
piece i was going to post this week and
i've i've pushed that off uh to a to a
future one uh but
but yeah we so do you have any cool
mushroom photos though
have you taken any awesome mushroom
photos taken a few nothing nothing great
i got
what was it a shaggy mane with a moth on
it some years ago yeah in olympia yeah
yes
yeah i've got a few but i haven't i
actually go digging
yeah yeah
all right well that brings us to the end
of
q a from episode 100
of the dark horse livestream my goodness
my goodness
uh join us right here next week for
episode 101 we'll be talking about
consensus and other things we don't know
what episode it's gonna be yes we do
okay
that resolved quickly at least
indeed
uh
what else do we want to say um get the
book if you haven't gotten the book yet
100 gatherers guide to the 21st century
uh seriously get it and and read it and
tell us what you think you'll dig it
it's wildly popular yeah yeah oh it's
and we didn't even say we're on the new
york times bestseller list again yes or
still from that yeah so we're on it for
the third week and that feels great and
it means that even though it actually
wasn't available for a while still
somehow people were buying it i don't
even know how that works
um but uh ask at your independent
bookstore like you know go in and say
hey do you have this book and uh see if
they'll get it right and if they say no
give them a look
yeah or just ask them to get it okay
yeah
yeah until i don't know how this
bookstore etiquette thing works i i'm
not having spent much time in buying
online you know
yeah
until next time be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside be
well everyone
[Music]
you